Сегодня многие живут в отчаянии, потому
что кошмар вокруг множится.
>> Первое моё послание человечества: вы
[музыка] не виноваты.
>> У нас времени мало.
>> У нас вообще нет времени. Мы сейчас
живём в темноте. Хоть бы кто-нибудь
включил свет.
>> А кто этот [музыка] свет выключил?
>> Человеку надо знать, что происходит. Нам
последнее время вообще ничего не
объясняет с точки зрения того, что на
самом деле происходит. [музыка] Он
только говорит: "Мы победим и там
посмотрим". А может быть, всё-таки нужно
посмотреть сначала перед тем, как
побеждать? Так и что делать людям, у
которых жизнь поставлена на паузу?
Спасибо большое, что нашли время
поговорить. Сегодня многие живут в
отчаянии, потому что кошмар вокруг
множится, и шансов, что его станет
меньше, ну, пока никаких. Вы согласны с
этим?
>> Ну, самое главное здесь можно сразу
сказать, что здесь нарушен по сути дела
закон Эшби, который звучит примерно так.
Как вы знаете, Эшби - это человек,
который имеет непосредственное отношение
к кибернетике, к искусственному
интеллекту и так далее. А сложность
управляющей системы должна быть как
минимум равна или выше сложности
управляемой системы, потому что в
противном случае неизбежны ошибки.
Сейчас система управления, которую мы
имеем, не справляется. Сложность такова,
что повсеместно идут массовые, крупные
ошибки. А поскольку народ не очень знает
хороший восточный принцип, сделал
ошибку, замри,
то сразу за этим они делают
дополнительную ошибку.
>> У нас времени мало.
>> У нас вообще нет времени. У нас
принимается решение в ситуации крайнего
дефицита. У нас странная ситуация, при
которой то сначала лихорадочная
активность, то полная тишина. Вообще
отсутствие всякой активности. Видимо,
так сказать, запас информации на анализ
ситуации кончился. И мы сидим и
просто-напросто ждём. Самое печальное,
что произошло за последнее время - это
потеря позитивного образа будущего,
который был в своё время. У нас был
прекрасный позитивный образ будущего у
СССР. Вспомните Тумана Сандрамеды или
Полдень Стругацких.
Помните, да?
>> Звёзды, космос,
>> звёзды, космос, дружба, мир и так далее
и тому подобное. Теперь у нас нет даже
пессимистического сценария. Вернее,
пессимистический есть, но мы стараемся
его не замечать. Я обнаружил, что люди,
которым я преподавал, используют знания
мои, в основном для преподавания другим,
а, во-вторых, для того, чтобы, так
сказать, не столько решать проблемы,
сколько их затушёвывать, сколько не
обращать на них внимания, сколько
>> как их глаза изменились, как их лица
поменялись.
>> Ну вот когда человек выходит, я говорю:
"Какова твоя мечта?"
И он не может сказать мечты,
когда мне приходится вытаскивать цели
через потребности. Ну, знаете, есть
такой способ вытаскивания через
потребности масло. Ты удовлетворён,
например, своей
выживаемостью, безопасностью,
наличием контактов и так далее и тому
подобное. И отсюда мы начинаем выводить
к целям. И внезапно выясняется, что они
боятся подступать к этому вопросу,
понимаете? Боятся.
Присутствующие мои психотерапевты из
центра практической психотерапии
сказали, что это было что-то ужасное.
Они тоже кое-что видят, что это чёрная
облако висела в буквальном смысле слова.
А я устал за первый день, так как не
вставал, ну, не знаю, давно. Я умею
восстанавливаться, у меня очень высокая
энергетика, но это был один из самых
сложных и тяжёлых семинаров в моей
жизни. Я понял простейшую вещь. Люди не
виноваты. Виноваты условия, которые
загнали в такое состояние, из которого
они не могут выйти. Понимаете? Первое
моё послание человечества: вы не
виноваты, но одновременно с этим вы
находитесь на той самой ситуации,
которой своё время находились, простите,
товарищи динозавры, которые, не сумев
приспособиться к изменению климата,
вымерли. Вот точно также будет, к
сожалению, вымирать и человечество,
потому что надежда на искусственный
интеллект в этом отношении беспочна.
хотя бы потому, что любой искусственный
интеллект первым делом, ну, начнёт
обращать внимание на конкурентов из
естественного интеллекта. А в какой
момент произошло это изменение, когда
люди перестали видеть цели?
>> Ну, произошло оно последнее время совсем
недавно, потому что, на самом деле, у
нас был действительно хороший период в
лучшем смысле этого слова оттепели без
упоминания автора этого термина.
[вздыхает] А потом появилась ситуация,
при которой нам последнее время вообще
ничего не объясняют с точки зрения того,
что на самом деле происходит или дают
настолько неудобоваримое объяснение, что
в результате люди начинают впадать в
некой ступор. Вот примерно это началось
где-то год назад. Таким образом,
насколько я понял, когда начались такие
не очень удачные изменения, на которые я
хотел бы обратить внимание власти имущих
по одной простой причине. Вы знаете, что
такое феномен порога в супружеских
отношениях?
Порок - это когда супруг или супруга
внезапно полярно меняет отношение к
своему партнёру. Раньше мне нравилось,
какая она игривая. Теперь я думаю, что
она просто капризная. Мне нравилась,
какая она сексуальная. Теперь я думаю,
что она просто ну, мягко говоря, не
совсем моральна. Поняли? В том-то и
дело, что нарастание изменений
происходит количественно, а скачок
бывает качественным. И сейчас нам
отчаянно нужна действительно ситуация,
при которой мы стабилизируем состояние,
хотя бы указав на перспективы,
возможности и так далее. Вы можете жить
в темноте. Мы сейчас живём в темноте.
Хоть бы кто-нибудь включил свет.
>> А кто этот свет выключил?
>> Ну давайте без политики. Вы это
прекрасно сами знаете. Там сейчас идёт
жесточайшая борьба. Мы сейчас находимся
не просто в экономическом, мы находимся
в управленческом кризисе. Дело в том,
что лучше к власти приходить не
собирается. Власть их обременяет. Власть
требует особого типа людей, которые
действительно нуждаются в этой власти
как таковой.
А так получилось, что теория всеобщего
равенства привела к тому, что, так
сказать, властью считается, что могут
заниматься все. И вообще все могут
заниматься всем. Все могут судить о
политике, все могут судить о педагогике,
все могут судить о психологии, все могут
судить о международных отношениях. Вот и
всё. На самом деле сейчас у нас в любом
случае без всяких психологических
обоснований можно выделить четыре типа.
которые, простите, существовали во всю
историю. Они ещё в Ведах описаны
индийских, и они были в древнерусских
вариантах. Сейчас у нас в настоящее
время есть элита,
обслуга,
и, простите, независимые. Быдла без
оскорбления. Это просто низший класс.
Это соответствует тому, что на самом
деле существовало на Руси изначально. То
есть у нас были смерды, те, которые
работали и которые, так сказать, больше
занимались тем, чтобы удовлетворяли сами
себя. Правда, Микола Селенинович,
известный богатыри, он вышел из смердов.
У нас были даже дальше веси, те, которые
пахали, торговали и так далее. У нас
были воины. Из воинского сословия
выбирались князья только. И на на
вершину занимали волховы.
Скажите, а где у нас сейчас место
волховов?
в районе смердов
или ниже. Вот и всё. Получается, что
здесь мы поломали ту пирамиду, которая
реально существовала тысячелетиями. Вот
так получилось в борьбе за слишком
поспешную демократию. Мы приняли
обманку, иллюзию свободы за свободу как
таковую. Нас, в общем-то, просто
обманули, если так говорить серьёзно.
В 1966 году было принято решение о
сворачивании работы по развитию, так
сказать, ну, скажем так, справедливого
общества. Там августовский пленум принял
немножко другое решение, формулировка.
Но мы свернули все свои программы, нам
объяснили, что у нас будет конвергенция,
детант и так далее. Нас купили,
купили нашу элиту. И до сих пор
патриотическая часть элиты, она вообще
не требует возврата социализма как
такового. Она требует возврата
солидарного мышления. Понимаете? Сейчас
проблема заключается в том, что при том
типе мышление, которое мы имеем, мы эту
цивилизацию утратим, мы её уничтожим.
Потому что есть два типа мышления.
Индивидуалистическое,
когда в центре находишься ты, я главное,
я строю вокруг себя. Есть другое
мышление солидарное, которое учитывает
мнение других и так далее и тому
подобное. Мы его сейчас даже у себя
утрачиваем. У нас настолько развился
уровень индивидуализма, что на самом
деле говорить о каком-то совместном
движении вперёд, простите, стадо
баранов, которые бежит в разные стороны,
довольно трудно.
>> А что делать простым людям? Давайте
вернёмся к ним от политики.
>> Просыпаться. Ну просыпаться не в плане
там на борь, на борьбу и так далее.
Просыпаться на жизнь. Понимаете? Я не
люблю, э, то по точки зрения, что у
верблюда два горба, потому что жизнь -
борьба. Это жизнь. Сейчас происходит
достаточно страшная вещь, очень чёткий
синдром отказа от жизни, синдром
остановки жизни.
Знаете, что это такое? Это было впервые
сформулировано в 1997 году на изучении
этих самых северных строителей, как их
называют, там полярников и так далее.
Выяснилось, что те живут, кто живёт на
севере, они считают, что их жизнь
начнётся тогда, когда они переедут на е
на юг или, как они говорят, на материк.
Но когда начали следовать этих людей,
которые пережидают, внезапно выяснилось,
что на самом деле эти люди не имеют
целей. Они их утратили,
потому что цели все там, на материке,
они не имеют сценария в действия, потому
что свой лучший сценарий - это куда
переехать, да, в какую местность и так
далее. Тем более не забывают, что они
адаптированы к одной местности и, к
сожалению, северяне уже не приживаются
на юге. Примерколепный писатель Куваев,
автор территории, который в средней
полосе очень быстро умер, не дожив до 50
лет. И вот это вот постоянно
откладывание, это не жизнь, это это
накопление, это мы будем когда-нибудь мы
будем жить. Вот сейчас произошло то, что
все мы ждём, когда это закончится, и в
результате автоматически мы адаптируемся
неврозом отложенной жизни,
синдромом отложенной жизни. Потому что
жить невыносимо, когда ты не знаешь, что
будет в конце концов. Скажите, а вы
знаете, что будет, если даже всё будет
хорошо? Нам даже не предложили. Ситуация
выхода. Нам только говорит: "Мы победим
и там посмотрим". А может быть, всё-таки
нужно посмотреть сначала перед тем, как
побеждать. Правильно? Да. И побеждаем
иногда как-то довольно странно. Я же
понимаю, что мы стараемся избежать диких
потерь, которые в своё время были во
Второй мировой войне, которые нам
приводят в качестве примера. Вот там мы
за 4 года всю Европу победили, да, и
потеряли 26 млн населения.
Ребят, вы хоть понимаете, что мы до сих
пор не можем покрыть эту демографическую
яму?
Что у нас бабы выли в голос? Потому что
мужиков не было ни одного.
Все впрягались в плуги. И сейчас мир
нарциссов, цивилизация нарциссов.
Всё управление, по сути, состоит из
нарциссов. А нарциссу самое главное-
возвеличивание собственной личности. И
вас он использует всегда только как
объект для манипуляции. Вы ему интересны
только до того времени, пока вы
подтверждаете его исключительность,
значимость и так далее. Он даже будет
создавать ситуацию, чтобы вы вынуждены
были доказать его значимость. Он нагл до
невозможности, хотя при этом самое
странное, что нарцисс - это жертва
травмы. Знаете, все основные
расстройства, они происходят от детства,
где чего-то не додали детям. Например,
нацисическая травма их не признавали их
значимость.
Поняли? Их родители, их папа и мама, они
были никто и ничто. Вот теперь они всем
доказывают, что они и кто, и что,
и что. И получается, что главное сейчас,
если эмпаты придерживается солидарность
мировоззрения, как вы поняли, это нарцис
исключительного, потому что главное для
них в жизни - это признание собственной
исключительности.
Кстати, эмпаты они никакие от слова
совсем. Они вообще не могут понять
другого человека. Они понимают только
свои модели по этому поводу. Вот и
ситуация, которая сложилась вам с чисто
психологической точки зрения. Понимаете?
Я, в общем-то, по складу своему
психоисторик в плане того, что я изучаю
исторические
моменты, в том числе с точки зрение
психологии. Это очень хорошо
объясняется.
>> Так и что делать людям, у которых жизнь
поставлена на паузу?
>> Жить, жить, вытягивать себя, понимаете?
Вытягивать себя потихонечку, вытягивать,
находить себе любое дело. Самое главное
здесь и не откладывать на там и тогда, а
искать что-то здесь и теперь. Хороший
день. Это не повод для того, чтобы
сурово с точки зрения так называемых
организованных делать то, что вы хотели.
Да плюньте, выйдите, посмотрите на
погоду, на природу и так далее. Ясно?
Намечайте хоть какие-то цели, намечайте
хоть какие-то праздники. Если говорить
конкретно, то у этих людей уже
повреждена линия времени. Есть такое
образование внутри человека, ну, в его
сознании, которое, так сказать,
определяет прошлое и будущее. Академик
северса, который мы оттолкнулись,
утверждал, что ли система, которая
столкнулась со сложностью, может ли
пережить.
Ну, не буду использовать её термологии
развития, то есть развиться для того,
чтобы совпадать со сложностью. Второе,
приспособиться. Тоже не буду. У него
такие названия роморфоз, идиадаптация.
Ну что делать биолог? Вот. То есть
ну приспособиться к ограниченному
количеству
сложностей, понимаете? ограничить свою
жизнь с каким-то существованием,
какими-то идеями, не больше того. Ясно?
Но большинство убирает третий путь,
деградация.
Деградация так, чтобы жить в этих
условиях. Ну и что? И так живём. То есть
меня больше всего убивает вот эта
неспособность людей понять, что ещё в
своё время Эрих Берн, а потом я в своих
трудах было понять, у него была
удачливость, но я его заменил на
благополучие, понимаете? Потому что
удача есть какая-то всё-таки довольно
эфемерная категория, хотя мы с ней
работаем и создаём её. А благополучие
заключается в том, что там есть шкала от
10ти до нуля. Ноль называется лягушка.
То есть человек, который по сути дела
действительно, так сказать, квакает в
своей болоте в лучшем случае и живёт там
и двигается только тогда, как в
известном анекдоте. Там лягушка попала в
канаву, её товарки попытались
вытаскивать, не вытаскивается, не
допрыгивает.
И они говорят: "Ну что ж, не переживай,
червячки тут тоже, наверное, водятся, мы
те будем навещать". Уходит, смотрит она
за ними: "Прыг, прыг-прыг".
Они говорят: "Как? Ты же не могла
вылезти?" Она говорит: "Я- то не могла,
но тут появился грузовик".
И вот то, что сейчас происходит,
это, возможно, грузовик для цивилизации.
Либо вылезем, либо останемся в своей
канаве дальше, но отнюдь не процветать.
Вы поняли? А скорее цвести как застойная
болото.
>> Если коротко вот так обозначить,
понятно, что вопрос может быть странный,
но что плохого в том, что жизнь стоит на
паузе и ты не ожидашь?
>> Очень просто. В том, что на самом деле
мозг - крайне ленивая система.
Мысли о том, что мозг активный, нет.
Главное занятие мозга - уменьшить
нагрузку на самого себя.
>> Леница.
>> Лень, да. Лень матушка, которая
оправдывается. Ах, у меня
прокрастинация, я нахожусь в мыслях и
так далее. Ничего подобного. Мозг
ленится и ленится прогрессивно.
Меритократия правительство Достойно
давно сменилась
в акистократии, как вы знаете. Ну, это
элементарный процесс, описан ещё
парнсом, поскольку именно
компетентностьс является основой для
продвижения. Компетентен, продвинули,
компетентент, продвинули, компетентент,
продвинули, то в конечном счёте на самых
верхушках иерархии находятся самые
некомпетентные. От чего остаётся только
вспомнить Петра?
как его совет, знаете, совет подчинённый
должен иметь вид легкой и придурковатый,
дабы дерзость воения не смущать
начальство.
Вот у нас примерно такой вариант. То
есть качество управления не к чёрту
абсолютно. И при этом управленческая
элита живёт в условиях парадигмальных,
так сказать, концепций, которые
абсолютно неверны. Первая концепция,
которая убивает нас и вообще весь мир,
хотя это не наше, это примат политики
над экономикой.
Даже Владимирович Ленин, нечасто
вспоминаемый товарищ, утверждал, что
экономика является, так сказать, только
лишь формой существования политики, но
она самостоятель, самодостаточна. А у
нас получается, что они сейчас ради
политической задачи, знаете какой, мне
не надо вам объяснять, они, к чёртвой
материноку
в состояние, о котором вообще трудно
говорить.
Какие костыли мы часто используем для
того, чтобы адаптироваться вот к этой
реальности в процессе, как бы сказать,
деградации своей?
>> С точки зрения классической парадигмы,
вселенная - это часы, заведенные Богом,
и нечего там вмешиваться, потому что
тогда они вообще чикать не будет.
Понятно? Наслаждайся тем, что можешь
время высмотреть, а больше у тебя
никаких возможностей. С точки зрения
квантовой парадигмы, вселенная - это
океан возможностей. Ну, это и гипотеза
Бома о непроявленной, проявленной
реальности, о том, что мы дружно,
коллективно проявляем ту реальность,
которая нам нужна. То есть мы сидим
сейчас в катастрофических ожиданиях, и
мы получаем катастрофические ожидания.
Если мы сидели в более оптимистических,
как доказали эксперименты, это
экспериментально доказано, что для
изменения, например, серьёзных изменений
в обстановке достаточно 1% населения той
территории, в которой вы, так сказать,
изменяете обстановку. Но это ещё лет
30-40 назад всё это было. Но это же надо
обладать фантастической силой для того,
чтобы, так сказать, не обращать на это
внимание, но использовать это в создании
цветных революций.
Ведь они все именно так и делаются.
Собирается группа товарищей в районе 1%,
которая начинает дружно выдвигать,
возможно, несовместимые лозунги,
несовместимые с жизнью. Всё понятно. И
происходят необходимые изменения. Вот
перед вами всё это везде смотрите. Так
всё и делает. Но применить это к
разумному, доброму, вечному невозможно.
Знаете, наверное, почему? Извините, я
уже немножко возбуждаюсь. Обычно я не
вовлекаюсь в это. Недавно был проведён
эксперимент этого паприша, ну, фамилии
не помню, но его считают, что
[тяжело вздыхает]
[вздыхает]
он является Эйнштейном XXI века.
Эксперимент был очень простой. Был была
создана экспериментальная модель рая.
Чак. Игра, в которой Что такое ад и что
такое рай? Рай - это когда не нужно
прилагать усилия, не нужно думать,
принимая решения, не нужно тесниться на
площади, не нужно бороться за ресурсы и
не нужно бороться за перемещение. Всё
это было восстановлено в этой игре. С
огромным изумлением выяснили очень
интересную вещь. Аватары, то есть это
были аватары. Игроки, которые играли в
эту игру, первым делом, начали бороться
за ресурсы, скучиваться на определённые
территории, на хабах и городах, узлах
каких-то, это самое, вот ездить строго
по протоколу и так далее и тому
подобное. Из чего этот товарищ сделал
разумный вывод. Основа зла лежит не в
том, что мы что-то не додумали, а,
простите, может быть, в человеческой
природе, которая не до конца развилась.
Может, она лежит вот в этом проникшем,
разъевше душу, как яд, как
радиация, индивидуалистического
представлении обо всём. Мысли о том, что
ресурсов мало и нужно отбить всё это
дело. Знаете, смешно. Но когда говорят,
что земля не может поддержить, я
вспоминаю работу Константина Эдуардовича
Целковского,
который ещё тогда просчитал, что при
условиях ээ даже проживания на земле 10
млрд, при справедливом распределении
земель на каждого человека придётся
примерно 50 га, из которых 20 га будет
свор взоне тропиков и субтропиков
на берегу моря. Вот так, понимаете? У
нас не хватает ресурсов. У кого?
У те, которые считают, что могут сидеть
сразу на 100 столях одновременно. У тех,
у которых, по сути дела, отбита психика,
абсолютно отмороженная. Знаете, есть
такая, правда, у нас говорят, что если
раньше поменяли чёрт знает, то теперь
говорят гарвардский психолог знает. Но
на самом деле гарвардские психологи
провели исследование и ввели интересное
понятие. Чака к деньгам - это патология,
это психическое заболевание.
уровня, по крайней мере, невроза. Она
обусловливается, так сказать,
неудачливости твоей собственной
структуры. Никто не психической, никто
не отрицает. Деньги нужны для
существования в таком количестве. Я
консультант, в том числе по управлению.
Последний из тех, после которых я
отказался, имел около миллиарда. Зачем
они ему? В частности, мы просчитали, что
для того, чтобы то просто-напросто
потратить деньги, ему необходимо
ежедневно тратить где-то 250.000
долларов.
Тем не менее, посмотрите, какая операция
получилась в результате. Это та самая
вещь, которая касается того, что
символом нашей жизни стал успех. А успех
- это в глазах у всех. Успех - это
внешнее. Пустить пыль в глазах.
Посмотрите, я на Мерседесе, я успешен.
Посмотрите, я в таком костюме, я
успешен. Даёт ли это удовлетворение?
Краткий миг в момент покупки этого
Мерседеса, костюм и так далее. А,
собственно говоря, благополучие, почему
я это заменил, эту модель сразу же
благополучие - это длительное состояние
внутреннего благосостояния. Уабрите,
внутреннего успех внешний. Он возникает
и длится ровно столько на финише. А
благополучие может длиться всю свою
жизнь. А мы сейчас ориентированы на
успех, на то, чтобы казаться, они быть,
и при этом собираемся ещё и жить
нормально. Да.
>> И как это благополучие достигнуть? А вы
знаете, дорогой мои, вот сейчас у нас,
давайте чётко скажем следующие две вещи.
У нас существует два типа психологов,
ну, даже три, пожалуй, психологи
академические, они изучают психологию,
честь им хвала за это. Психологи
прикладные, они изучают определённые
отрасли этой психологии, например,
инженерная, психология труда, психология
секса даже уже появилась и так далее.
Есть практические психологи, которые
занимаются тем, что практически правят
мозги людям. Эти практические психологи
называются психотерапевтами по одной
простой причине. Психолог не
психотерапевт, вы поняли?
Психолог - это гаишник, который говорит,
что вы не так поступили на дороге,
поэтому попали в аварию. Он даже не
может выступать в качестве инструктора
для того, чтобы на площадке показать
вам, как водить в этой жизни. И,
соответственно, с этим он тем более не
выступает ремонтником вашей пострадавшей
машины, вашей пострадавшей души. Но
одновременно с этим психотерапевты, а не
психологи, обратили внимание? Они делают
страшную штуку. Они освобождают людей от
влияние любых, понимаете? Они чистят
мозги, человек уже не является то тем
самым клише, которые из него хотели
получить. Более того, он становится
счастлив без тех морковок, за счёт
которые его дёргают. Он становится
свободным, потому что снимается с тех
крючков, на которого держали. Ясно? И
поэтому общая идеология всего мира по
отношению к ним такая слегка
неудобрительная.
Понятно, почему, да? Вот и всё.
>> Вы дали определение успеха, а
определение благополучия, что это такое?
>> Ну давайте я немножко поясню это на
примере двух моделей счастья. Существуют
две основные модели счастья. Это
гедонистическая гедония. И второе - это
эвтодинамическая. Это эвдоминия.
>> Второе не знаю, что такое. Ну в том-то и
дело, что все не знают, что гедаимизм -
это кратковременное довольствие, которое
получается от, так сказать, принятия
чего-то сладкого, приятного и так далее.
А эдомонизм - это удовольствие, которое
ты получаешь от достижения выполнения
дел. Это удовольствие, предвкушение от
выполнения, в том числе. Понимаете? Это
когда ты действительно получаешь
удовольствие от выполненное дело. В
тесте есть даже такой вопрос: что мне
больше всего устраивает? Наслаждение
после работы, ощущение выполненных дел.
Я не могу жить без ощущения выполненных
дел. А теперь представьте, если бы так
жили другие, да, каких бы успехов мы бы
достигли? Это же связано с реальными
делами, а не с фу-фу-фу-фу. А мы
получили общество гедонистов тосклевых,
которые ходят, так сказать, всё больше и
дальше в кайф. 50 лет назад было
проведено исследование воздействия на
ретикулярную формацию крысов на центр
удовольствия. Их подключили к центру
удовольствия. Нажимая лапой, крыса
вызывала импульс удовольствия. Все крысы
померли
от голода и истощения, потому что они
только и делали, что нажимали на лапки,
понимаете?
>> То есть не ели, а сразу удовольствие.
>> Да. Есть. Могу привести ещё более
шокирующий момент, э, который называется
Вселенная 25. Он был крысам был создан
абсолютный крысиный рай. тепло, еды
навалом, свет, никакой опасности, ничего
нет и так далее. Знаете, чем окончился
эксперимент? [вздыхает][тяжело вздыхает]
Крысы стали есть друг друга при обелии
еды, перестали размножаться, занялись
гомосексуализмом и начали вымирать одна
за другой.
Эксперимент оказался настолько
чудовищный. Получается, что если вы
отказываетесь от каких-то выполнения
каких-то требований, переходите на
гедонизм и даже начинаете изобретать,
что вот хорошо при как раньше при
коммунизме обязательно хотя работы было
2 часа. Кто сказал, что работа - это
каторга? Это просто неверный подход к
этому делу. Ясно? Вы же с огромным
удовольствием носитесь, например, как
мои знакомые по грязному полю, в грязной
форме и гоняете круглый предмет, который
не имеет никакого смысла. Вы получаете
удовольствие.
Точно так же можно я могу перенести это
удовольствие на любой ваш вид
деятельности. И мы на самом деле
занимаемся перепрограммированием ваших
программ. С самого раннего детства вам
внушали определённые точки зрения,
которые вы считаете сейчас естественными
и вашими. Они и не ваши, и
неестественные.
Неестественны они, потому что они были
внушены в то время, которое не сейчас.
Правильно? Ваши родители вам внушали
когда? Мне так вообще в шестидесятые
годы, правильно?
>> Мне в девяностые.
>> Вам в девяностые, поэтому вы ближе к
этой реальности, но у вас модуль модус
девяностых годов при этом, понимаете,
заразился как таковой. Вот это всё
неверное мировоззрение, которое вы
реализуете в своём поведении. Сценарий
вашей жизни дарован вашей матушкой. И
даже если ваша мать умрёт, вы всё равно
будете перед ней мысленно отчитываться,
выполнил, не выполнил. Хотя при этом
сценарий может быть совершенно
идиотский.
Вот и всё. Да, мы изучаем сценарий, мы
меняем сценарий, мы много чего можем
делать. Знаете, недавно я начал работу
по созданию, простите, бота Сергей
Ковалёв. Я не собираюсь, не думаю, что я
её доведу в конце концов. Хотя можно
создать электронную, так сказать,
сущность, потому что мне при всём том,
что я здоров и даже где-то в чём-то
молод, мне 72 года, извините, это время
достаточно большое.
>> То есть функция заложена в нас получать
удовольствие от работы?
>> Нет. У нас заложена функция получать
удовольствие от того, что мы поставим в
качестве источника удовольствия.
>> То есть мы сами должны выбрать.
>> Мы сами, но мы не выбираем. Общество
сажает нас на иглу гедонизма, потому что
элементарно можно управлять любым
человеком, если уменьшить количество его
благ. Машинов на прокат, квартиры на
прокат и всё прочее. Всё вы идеальный
объект для управления. Стоит вам только
дёрнуться, как машина исчезает, квартира
исчезает, всё прочее и так далее. Идеал,
так сказать, самого справедливого в мире
капиталистического общества. Вот и всё.
А люди, тем более смотрят достаточно
поверхностно, к сожалению. Они давно уже
разучились видеть причину и подлинные,
так сказать, вещи. Возвращаясь к
благополучию, вот вы сказали один из
тезисов - это получать удовольствие от
достижения целей. Ну, предположим, там
ты естественно, но это не обязательно, я
могу вам перевернуть, но сказать, что
это отдельный тип удовольствия. Но
Марина Влади, которую Владимир Высоцкий
сделал алкоголичкой, была тоже вдемичка.
Знаете, в чём? Она выяснила, что
алкоголики получают наил высшее
удовольствие перед тем, как напьются,
когда тащат домой бутылки. Интересный
вывод. То есть эдодемическое
удовольствие - это вообще удовольство от
достижения чего-то, от процесса,
понимаете, а не от финиша, который
длится вот такой вот малость, а на него
выкладываете всю свою жизнь. Так что тут
нельзя сводить, что это благое
стремление к труду. Это просто форма
жизни людей, у которых есть некоторые
способности к организованности,
понимаете? А всё остальное - это,
извините за выражение, фигня.
>> Так из чего ещё формируется
благополучие? Ну, формула благополучия
давно выявил. Это совокупность, так
сказать, трёх величин. Это, собственно
говоря, первая величина - это
эффективность программ. У вас куча
программ заложено, они автоматизированы.
Если бы они не были автоматизированы, вы
бы думали, как та блондинка, помните,
которая умерла, когда от неё отняли
бринетку, а потом выяснили, что бринетка
и говорила в ухо: "Вдох-выдох,
вдохвыдох, вдохвыдох, вдох-выдох". Ясно?
Но вашу программу устарели.
Они не соответствуют нынешней
реальности. Даже программа
взаимоотношений, вся программа всего
прочего, а это автоматические вещи,
которые вы сетовате, почему тебя так не
везёт? Почему у меня так не получается?
Поэтому получается, что на самом деле
первое условие благополучия - это
адекватность программ. Поняли? Мы
смотрим область, в которой человек
неадекватен, ну, то есть неуспешен,
понимаете? И начинаем смотреть, за счёт
чего. Второе условие, как ни странно,
это удовлетворённость. Не счастливость.
Счастье, как вы понимаете, возникает
потом, постфакм после этого, а
удовлетворённая ситуация. Ясно? А что
здесь главное? Карта.
Если вас в детстве покусала крупная
собака или испугала, вы теперь боитесь
даже вот таких вот собачек. Правильно?
Почему? У вас в голове карта в на
которой написано: "Собаки злые кусучие
существа", правильно? И в результате вы
живёте по старой карте. Скажите, а вы не
пробовали, например, имея карту Москвы
XVI века, столетия ездить по Петербургу
XIго? Вот по аналогии вам понятно? Всё
ваше мировоззрение, всё ваше возрение о
реальности - это совокупность карт
устаревших, а часто вообще изначально
порочных. Русские идут, русские гады и
так далее и тому подобное. Любое
идеологическое воздействие - это
распространение новой карты, вбивание в
голову. И делается это достаточно быстро
и достаточно легко. И последнее, смыслы,
потому что на самом деле, если вы не
видите смысла в том, что вы делаете, то
в этом случае вы делаете это зря. Как
говорил, если не ошибаюсь Франку, жизнь
одновременно и глупая, и полна смысла.
Если не смеяться над первым и не
задуматься над вторым, она становится
совершенно никчемной. То есть ты должен
соответствовать норме, правильно?
Главное, чтобы ты был нормален.
А нормы - это же посредственность.
Существует очень интересное определение
вот этой нормы и посредственности.
Застрявшиеся на середины холма. Они
пытались подняться на холм, но застряли
посередине. Ни туда, ни сюда.
Улавливать. У нас совершенно другая
вещь. Жизнеспособность.
То, ради чего существует психология -
это жизнеспособность, способность
выживать в нечеловеческих условиях, в
том числе за счёт игры на этих самых
вещах. Мы прекрасно знаем, как
приспособить человека к любой
реальности, где это надо. Ну и что? Мы
не участвуем в образовательном процессе,
кроме только своей узкой специальности.
Мы готовим людей и так далее. Но это же
должно осуществляться в несколько
большем масштабе.
>> Я согласен с вами. Но а как человеку не
бороться с реальностью, которая сейчас
есть, да, а использовать её для
достижения своих целей?
>> Для начала понять следующее. Существует
ээ восемь основных концепций квантовых,
которые объясняют воздействие не
нефизическое воздействие на физический
мир. Естественно, я вам сейчас
рассказывать блистая рудиться не буду,
но в конце бома, как вы поняли, исходит
соратник Эйнштейна, которого он, кстати,
был другом, очень полюбил по одной
простой причине, потому что когда был
введён принцип копенганский принцип уж
прости о том, что наблюдатель влияет на
наблюдаемое,
то есть что мы прямо управляем,
потерялся детерминизм происходящего. На
самом деле там всё достаточно просто.
Есть непроявленный мир, огромный
непроявленный мир, океан, симфония
возможностей. Он отличается, как ни
странно, не структуры, а глубиной. Мы
вообще шастаем по поверхности океана и
отдельные волны видим. Глубину мы вообще
не знаем. Если бы у нас было мышление,
которое позволяло это делать,
психическая настройка, в этом случае мы
бы получали массу полезной для себя
информации. Правильно? Так вот один из
выводов: голографическая голографичность
Вселенной. Вот я иду и слышу: "Всё
пропало, всё пропало в любой форме". Мой
взгляд - это лазер. Если я сейчас
направлю в свой свой взор и внимание на
то, что всё пропало, всё пропало,
во-первых, я в это поверю, а дальше оно
просто пропадёт.
По целому ряду законов. Например, закон
Томаса, согласно которому
неверное мнение, которое остаётся
мнением большинства, осуществляется.
Это даже официально закон Томоса.
Поняли? То есть, по крайней мере, ну
перестаньте встревать во все эти дела,
поймите. Нет, вы, конечно, не
суперсущество, вам до него как знаете,
до хрен значко кого. Но тем не менее
поймите, что вы сами создаёте свою
судьбу, вляпываясь во все эти мысли. Вы
начинаете раскручивать, заполняете
содержание сознания. Даже без всякой
эзотерики, вы настраиваете восприятие на
то, чтобы видеть именно плохое.
А в чём корень наших глупых решений?
>> Корень наших глупых решений в том, что
мы для решения используем не то, не так
и не тогда, когда надо. Потому что,
видите ли, в чём дело. У человека два
полушария. Знаете, наверное, да? Но не
все знают, что Роджерс Перис за открытие
билатеральности полушарий получил
Нобелевскую премию. Он доказал, что по
сути дела у нас не просто два полушария,
у нас две разных индивидуальности, если
хотите. То есть левополушарный логик,
скептик, сухарь и так далее. И
правополушарный творец, интуит, но,
правда, при этом депрессант, потому что
он видит в жизнь слишком много видит в
жизни. Всё понятно. Между ними
мозолистое тело и взаимодействие между
полушариями почти не существует. Это
доказано экспериментально. Человеку
закрывали доступ к левому полушарю и
давали запомнить что-то. Потом
спрашивали, восняли, правое полушарие
это помнят, поскольку вы не закрывали, а
лево? Нет, не помнт. Совершенно
по-другому. На этом построена одна из
самых простых систем психотерапии.
Билатеральная стимуляция, когда вы не
приятный материал одновременно даёте
увидеть и левом, и правому полушарию,
потому что правое страдает, а левое
логически может что-то объяснить.
Улавлить, но одновременно с этим
выяснили более. В общем, короче говоря,
80% гениев право глушарники.
>> Так, и как мы глупое решение принимаем?
Почему? Потому что мы основываемся на
левом логическом, а закрываем для себя
океан возможностей. Условно говоря,
правое полушарие позволяет нам
подключаться к непроявленной реальности,
космическому интернету, коллективному,
бессознательному. Ясно? Где есть
подлинное решение. Этим занимался Карл
Густов Юнг, который я сейчас с
удовольствием изучаю заново. Грубо
говоря, в результате работы через левое
полушарие вы пользуетесь
недоброкачественными качества сайтами, с
недоброкачественной информацией или
вообще без информации. Ясно?
правопорушая видит суть, правопорушая
работать совершенно в другом режиме.
Визионерство, оно автоматически,
интуитивно получает право правильное
решение.
>> А если говорить про взрослость, сколько
действительно взрослых людей?
>> Скажите, а вот если говорить о
взрослости, давайте возьмём концепцию
Роберта Эрика Берна, который утверждает,
что есть три инстанции у нас внутри, и
мы основываемся на одной из этих
инстанций. Три эгосостояния.
Эгосостояние ребёнка.
Эгосостояние родителя, эгосостояние
взрослого, эгосостояние ребёнка - это,
по сути, не случайно делится как минимум
по эмоциональным плана на солнечного и
сумеречного ребёнка. Солнечный ребёнок
считает, что всё хорошо, сумечный, что
всё плохо. Ну, кстати, это часто
связано, как вы поняли, с полушариями.
Сумореничные дети, они зато интуитивны,
к сожалению. Я левополушарник, видите,
это простой способ. Право полушарник.
Это простой способ выяснить.
>> Как ты сводишь руки, да? Вот
>> они работают на перекрест. Поэтому самый
простой тест выглядит так. Первое, какая
рука у вас является сверху? У меня
левая, видите? И вот так я сделать не
могу, мне неприятно. И второй тест. Вот.
Вот. О, сразу видите, у меня левая рука
пошла сверху и хрен хочу сделать что-то
и так далее.
>> Это такой примитивный тест на всё это
дело. Просто я так понимаю, что большое
количество людей, хотя они по паспорту
взрослые, на самом деле живут как дети.
>> Ничего подобного. Вот. Вот теперь мы
перейдём к следующему. Скажите, среди
политиков вы много можете назвать людей,
которые взрослые? Если дитё - это
человек, который старается сделать
по-своему, даже если это неверно, да ещё
при этом может быть сумеречным, да ещё
при этом может быть, извините, ээ
адаптированным для детём. Так и только
так, а никогда больше не будет. Родитель
- это наше всё, наши моральные нормы.
Делать так, потому что так всегда было и
так далее. А взрослый - это единственный
человек, который способ действовать
эффективно. Ваш вопрос, сколько? Очень
мало. Не случайно сейчас, как вы знаете,
помните, теперь возраст молодости нет.
Сейчас он поменялся. Сейчас молодость до
45 лет.
до 45 лет вы молоды, потому что,
извините, но есть один физиологический
коррелянт молодости. Прифронтальная
кора, которая принимает основное
решение, тот самый, который здесь
находится, она окончательно
формировалась раньше, после 25 лет, в
некоторое время до 20 лет, а сейчас
действительно формируется чуть ли не в
40. То есть до со0ка этот субъект,
получивший высшее образование и прочее,
соображать не умеет.
>> Это правда так? То есть долго так
формируется? Ну, у кого как. Кто-то в 14
лет управляет полком, как
небезызвестный, так сказать, Гайдар.
Кто-то Но раньше было раньше. Раньше
жизнь была короткая, и не было условий,
так сказать, на это дело. Поэтому,
так сказать, Грибоедов закончил
университет в в 12 лет. А вы, кстати,
помните, сколько он факультета закончил?
Три. В 12 лет университета. А требования
тогда же не отличались. Тогда
действительно было раннее формирование,
а сейчас, к сожалению, люди у нас
формируются достаточно поздно. У нас
сейчас, но зато у нас у них увеличилась
возможности для изменения своей
собственной судьбины. Знаете, как-то
когда исследовали нобелевских лауреатов
и потом просто знаменитых людей, со
заявлением выяснили, что они их можно
поделить по одному типу. Они либо
концептуалисты, которые с самого начала
знали, чем они будут заниматься, что они
будут делать и так далее. Извините за
название, не я назвал автора. А-вторых,
он назвал экспериментатора. Пример
концептуалиста Мосард с четырёх лет
музыка. Правильно. Можете назвать кучу
тех, которые раннее развитие, у которых
ранняя та самая правда и ранняя смерть.
А вторые экспериментаторы, они начинают
реализовывать себя после 40 лет.
Действительно, после 40 лет. И это часто
является их второй жизнью, которую
многие из вас, дорогие наши зрители,
откладываете. Вы прекрасно знаете
Финимора Купера, которого, правда, я до
сих пор, как в этом юмористическом
рассказе, некоторые уже сейчас опять его
воспроизво.
А вы знаете о том, что он до 47 лет был
заурядным таможенником на английской
таможне, потом вышел на пенсию, ему было
нечего делать, и родился Финимор Купер,
писатель, автор кучи вещей, которые в
своё время занимали, так сказать, других
людей. А вы знаете о том, что архитектор
Райт, великий создатель этих проницаемых
домов, едешь вечером, всё видно, но
красиво. Он же, собственно говоря,
выстрелил после шестидесяти. Поэтому
кончайте ограничения для себя. Один из
ответов на возможные вопросы. У вас нет
ограничений, кроме того, что у вас стоит
непосредственно там. Просто грузовика
нет поблизости. Возможно, вы слишком
хорошо живёте или слишком адаптированы.
У вас нет возможности и желания бросать
вызов обстоятельствам. создавать
действительно серьёзно новую жизнь. И
слишком, кстати, привязаны к
стереотипам. А результат имеем то, что
имеем. Вы говорите: "Боже, вот
развалился весь мир, когда в двадцать
шестом году было принято решение Трамп
пришёл и так далее". Трамп особстать.
У него есть заключение американской
ассоциации психиатров его полной
непригодности к этому делу. Но поскольку
он не соглашался на это обследование,
они его обследовали заочно, то оно не
имеет силы. Он может от него отказться.
Но не в этом дело. А дело в том, что уже
20 лет перед этим мир страдал аномией, о
которой никто не знает. Что такое
аномия?
Ой, господи, для отдельно отдельный
разговор. Анамия - это отказ от норм.
Во всём мире произошёл отказ от норм, от
моральных правил, от обязательств, от
всего прочего. Этим занимались
достаточно крупные социологи, так
сказать, тот же Роберт Мартон в
современности. Они доказали, что во всех
ситуациях неопределённости
происходит ухудшение нормативности.
Поняли? Да. Чем хуже, чем больше
неопределённость, особенно переходного
периода, тем больше отсутствие
нормативности, тем больше себе люди
позволяют вправо, влево без побега и так
далее. А Мртон к этому ещё довёл то, что
на самом деле это происходит,
потому что мир утратил цель с точки
зрения Мэртона. Единственная цель,
которая даётся людям - это существование
и рост в определённой иерархии за счёт
выполнения определённых правил.
Но поскольку, во-первых, не все это
могут делать, на всех иерархии не
хватит, и не всем это нравится, то в
результате получилось четыре типа
отклонения от этого дела. Первое из
которых является конформизм. Я делаю
вид, что я работаю, я ни черта не делаю,
но ко мне никто не пристанет. Второй вид
заключается в том, ну, адаптация,
принимает такую модель. Ясно. Третий
тип, Мртон его назвал, очень смешно,
инновационный. это преступники,
коррупционеры, все прочие инновационная
работает в этой системе, ясно, так
сказать, инновации проявляют. А
последний тип ретритный - это когда вы
начинаете играть в гоблинов и эльфов
где-то на поляне и только там живёте, а
здесь вообще никакого функции не несёте.
Я слишком хорошо помню, что когда я
объяснил одну политическую штуку, запись
шла на студии Масфильм, там тогда сидели
товарищи и так далее, мне сказали: "Это
потрясающе, мы немедленно это дадим в
эфир, это всё будет". Я сказал: "Да,
скорее всего, руководство не даст вам
это в эфир". Так и получилось. Самое
смешное, что эта передача, вызвавшая
действительно большие, прошла в соседней
стране. У нас нет. Её сняли со сфера,
хотя она писалась для эфира, понимаете?
Потому что надеюсь, что что-то от нашего
разговора останется.
>> Какие книги вы бы посоветовали прочесть
нашим зрителям для того, чтобы лучше
понимать себя и этот мир?
>> Наверное, знаете, я бы сейчас
проявлю изрядное самодовольство, скажу,
что две книги знакомого мне человека
Ковалёва Сергея Викторовича, который он
списал специально для того, чтобы
объяснить то, что происходит. Ибо с
момента наступления ковида,
по сути дела, первого всадника
Апокалипсиса, чума,
было ясно, что мир начинает трещать по
швам и надо что-то делать. Я
проанализировал все тенденции этого и
создал вот эту книгу, которая называется
Энциклопедия выживания.
[тяжело вздыхает]
Открушение к новым возможностям
руководство по пользовательно жизни в
трудную эпоху неприятных перемен. До сих
пор народ мне пишет, что когда у меня
что-то случается, я листаю вашу книгу и
нахожу ответ. Вторая книга называется
Под психологии великого пробуждения или
как обрести счастливое будущее, не
заблудившись настоящим и не застряв в
неудачном прошлом. Книга для тех, кто
хочет процветать и жить, а не выживать и
прозеть. Есть даже интересная форма
адаптации к этому. Вот у нас два
последних поколения, зумеры и нынешние
маленькие альфачи альфа, они
отреагировали на ситуацию, которая
возникает. И зумера и альфа в
профессиональном плане ищут не работу, а
образ жизни. Поняли?
Какая работа обеспечит возможность их
образа жизни? Они возвращаются в жизнь,
в бытиё жалкого существования, потому
что, извините,
ээ работа для жизни, но жизнь для работы
всё-таки не совсем правильно. Согласны?
Так что получается, что сейчас
определённые процессы пойдут. Им поэтому
легче идти на слабые профессии, на
слабые технологичные профессии, которые
быстро осваивать, нежели, так сказать,
на более сложные, потому что многие виды
деятельности - это жизнь.
Вот, в частности, [смех] нам счасть,
кстати, психотерапия тоже, как сказал
психотерапевт, великий психотерапевт,
уже не помню кто, честно говоря,
психотерапевты
умирает за столом работы с клиентом.
>> Спасибо вам большое за это интервью, за
этот разговор. Я надеюсь, что многим он
будет полезен и кому-то, может быть,
действительно поменяет жизнь.
>> Я тоже очень на это надеюсь, потому что
всего-навсего, ребятки, начните жить.
Немножко раскройте глаза, чтобы верить
мир. Перестаньте верить догмам, в том
числе, которые вы считаете святыми, и
будет вам тогда счастье. Только живите.
Тот способ проживания этой жизни, э,
напоминает добровольную каторгу,
которой и вериги, и цепи, и неудобное
месторасположение вы выбираете для себя
сами. А потом всю жизнь из вас
отстаиваете мысли о том, что это
действительно ваш выбор и так нужно
жить.
>> Спасибо большое. Пожалуйста.
เฮ